all right hey we are laughs welcome to
your Lord forecast and the Lord's are
gaming dotnet episode number 118 and
it's another glorious Sunday and we're
back at the roundtable and the Lord's
Day and today we've got some ds5 tech
impressions Marvel Ultimate Alliance
three impressions
spider-man is the superhero do switch
upgrade we go get right into it
so let's introduce the oh the total boss
no Starsky oh shout out to sob hopefully
these sorry Thomas will be joining us in
progress as well as actually
unfortunately Lord added you know saying
he's going through something right now
so send some love to Lord addict he's
not doing too well physically you know
I'm saying we wishes wishing okay so
definitely hit him up make sure to check
on him he's alright but again we got to
two horsemen the original oh geez in
this piece you already know the
Incredible Hulk of this aka the XS game
oh the lord of combat sports king of the
statues who demands nothing less than
that premium experience it is the leader
of the fraud alert movement beloved lord
care how you doing sir I'm doing
incredible yes sir
I'm gonna tell you right now I've never
been so happy to be so wrong about a
fight Oh shout-out to the fighting
senator out of the Philippines you know
you got to remember where Holyfield
became the holy warrior oh yeah oh when
I am Mike Tyson became mighty Mike Tyson
then I get kind of leery when these guys
take on the secondhand name let me lean
in the career
menti self but you know what I saw
yesterday and people are yelling out the
Fountain of Youth as I analyze the fight
while the fight was going on Manny did
exactly what I thought Manny would do
what Keith didn't understand was the way
Manny closes distance he closes distance
with his legs hmm if you see Manny's
calf muscles
Manny's calf muscles are incredible yeah
he's always had so in the first round
when he caught Keith unaware keith was
tripped up it was a solid shot but when
you off your square you go down okay is
that all right okay all right first time
he was on his butt man um what I respect
about Keith right after that moment mmm
Keith decided okay I'm gonna start to
get to work because I thought in the
first run actually I thought Keith was
winning the first round until it
happened hmm and then you know Manny put
two in a pocket for you know the two a
10-8 round in between the pocket and
then he started doubting himself in the
second round
hmm but he wasn't like willing it like
mix up he was no no the whole night
keith was willing to engage and he was
throwing punches like I thought he would
do oh my god I thought he would throw
two shots I thought he wouldn't mix it
up but he just thought Manny would stop
throwing punches at some point time you
don't give a damn how you feel about it
he wasn't I felt so good for Manny when
he got into the zone it was like the
third or fourth round and the minute of
RAM Keith moved four shots
Manny dip slipped slid through two shots
and did an alley shuffle with his feet
that's when I knew he was in the zone he
was locked in mmm that's what's up
so now after this the talk I'm hearing
is like okay first of all once Earl
destroys Porter in September that's
gonna be a destruction on a level that
people don't understand like Porter's
not coming to get that smoke he's off
fight you know what a fight but what
happens is over a period of time
Spence breaks you down well yeah he's
like a tree chocolate he didn't crunch
you you know everybody's like oh but me
for Mikey Garcia he go in 12 rounds if
you listen and I told y'all ahead of
time I listened to you cuz you basically
said he let the boy live he's letting
the boy he was allowing him to breathe
and every time he's a sadist because he
really wanted to punish him because he
really didn't like my community this
said afterwards he really couldn't stand
I mean he wanted to take him down a
notch
um Porter he respects Porter so he can
get poured up out of it he's gonna beat
water to the body bag mm-hmm oh no
challenges around slow-mo you guys this
is slo-moes channel yet yes he's all
happy I'm so happy he's doing it I
actively watch people I mean that
comment I get my likes in I may not
comment down there like some weirdo I'm
just like a weird voice wow if a real
I'm on the top just like that I
[Music]
appreciate anyone just watching the
channel you know watching the videos
it's all good you know like I like make
stuff about what I really enjoy ain't
gonna be about like all the others you
know Xbox Sony and I don't like not just
talk about games I like and that's about
it really yeah yeah I love all the
support man I appreciate you guys know
it's long overdue brother we always like
you takes you know saying and it's just
you've always been passionate so I
thought
the transmission was happening for you
it was only a matter of time you know
this right right
salute and we got Laura wrapping the
bill what's going on prep let me time
but we've got you with yes sir your
timing is impeccable man I just actually
wrapped up a rant I know I was listening
I've been feeling the passion lately man
just not for you I'd be in a lot of
positive life's like me and stuff the
community some negative but mostly
positive though it's been it's been
great like we've you know we've got a
lot of support more recently so you know
well I think every one of the
communities really really really they
really need to get behind you because
you definitely wanted them positive
dudes it's gonna be at e3 next like it's
it's a bucket list make sure it's
happened that's right
oh man so playing blood-stained my it's
my spiritual successor to Castlevania
obviously the gears fire tech test yes
you will save said thoughts I know yeah
you know get back at a destiny believe
in that okay slow-mo what have you been
playing sir actually one of our topics
Marvel Ultimate Alliance I'm literally
right now on a boss battle like I know
certain laws might be playing Ultimate
Alliance 3 been playing still playing
Borderlands 2 and you know try and get
through the DLC with all six of my vault
hunters I actually did a little bit of
Destiny yesterday shoutout to the ashen
Lucas
who helped me with some real basic stuff
that like nothing most destiny has to be
like you didn't know to do that I'm Noah
I'm lost like the whole the whole
opulence of the chalice yeah defense and
I had shot the Kaiba too
we were doing a - uh boss moving the
chest all salty a chance to Jersey
what's going on y'all it's good to see
ya
Oh shop shout out because um I got a
given cut you some slack because crime
me was playing and we were like yo they
don't do a good job of telling you what
to do in the new action not at all like
what are these rules there's no real
expert like they are sometimes they
assume you've been rocking and they
forget sometimes people just jump in
right during this expansion right right
so you jump in new young people hit me
up like shout you a child - Eric Jackson
another breath he hit me up called
peoples on yo I just start playing
that's Nicki Minaj yeah Sony like what's
going on and I'm like oh I there's a
little ray jump balls for people that
can't sit down and do a hole rate I like
what they did with it um the only
problem like you know that the legendary
Lord brings money into buildings going
oh baby oh there you go we got legs my
boy from tick - all this is great
any money maybe money what's going on
money we got bro salut but let's talk be
my talk to be a solo be what is going on
there what you could play a bro I was
actually playing at Marv Ottoman life
everyone's playing this game so do it
then I'm good then i'ma join you are the
Ultimate Marvel and see you
ok you know what my problem is this game
money will see a lot of unions I'm gonna
tell you right now this has I said to
myself I'm gonna go to the list on game
pass and I'm gonna try one new game a
week so the fact I'm playing destiny the
battle chases now it's some new mage
game plus I'm playing on the last the
final station right so but it's this new
mage game that just came out and it's
just a little 16-bit throwback ever then
I'm stuck alone right now that I'm
starting to love again and it feels good
because they got actually right no
slowdown games are looking really good
music it's there and also I play blazing
clone I'm all you know about that we did
the interview with them we got the
exclusive fact or an axe it's too much
for me to play the boss
you can't justify with your back law
Lord saw the softer Damas has rolled it
keeps in plain experience what is going
on sir till the mansion and everything
is good man before I start out and talk
about what I'm playing I need to give a
big shout-out to Papa solve Oh
after 50 plus years as part of the
workforce Friday he bid a deer timing on
the horizon I think it's a wrap filled
up yeah that's all he's about right now
right I just came back running for home
with my sister like move some stuff
around she's a they paint in the house
or whatever so I was just like sit down
he was over there and he was like what
do you need me to do them just just sit
in chess it's just a little Papa sir
yeah always show love a salute I love
him for the babalu yo hey beat likes all
pops had to the club
like you know there so we should watch
it was a spot in the in the Bronx to be
X Chad the man he probably know and then
all over there not too far from the
point right let's see for the plan was
say 138 8th and it was such a cool setup
you get your drink or we had to fight it
was just the spot to be you know they
like a rock you gotta remember like the
thing is my pop spot was basically mall
the people that played baseball with
which were like 99% for Regan people
right I'm not even like I my family's
like the outlier like
exactly I'm hang out with everybody some
people are very closed-minded whatever
so they so I'm like I'm bringing my
friends over to watch the fight and my
was like cool no problem
and then we are young you don't realize
these things and then when you crazy
system
I realize King and car was the best just
really say something real quick um when
I was a amateur and I was fighting it
would be me him and I ran Berkeley
chillin right and sweepy was a pro and
anytime we went to Virginia whatever I
ran but you know that's the spot we go
over there he had a basketball court in
his house it was the craziest thing I've
ever seen in my life
and all he did was import knowledge and
was the most chill dude and you know a
funny pranks to type do comedian very
nice man and for him to pass by car
accident it sucks so bad that we
actually lost a very great human being
if not one of the greatest boxers who
ever will know about your box
absolutely you said it best when we were
talking cuz you were like he was Floyd
without power before Floyd like he
he was such a defensive wizard
you know the just gave you a shout out a
little bit earlier about helping me out
Luka yeah to get his weight up
you know he said he's a baby guardian
now
I don't know let's get it moving we go
crazy with salute everybody come and
pulling up in the realm of course you
have Laura kognito the Lord of the
cooperative experience in gaming ninja
himself they should know we said we
don't get into the realness of the ILP
for me honestly has just been on so I
shot shout out to all my boy Jameson we
saw spider-man last night far from home
for the first time I got an R&R up on on
ILP channel right now so check that out
a lot of good positive vibes on that but
on the neck gaming Wiseman is been
obviously destiny season opulence has
been late I've been doing that I'm
obviously gonna get into that gears v
you're not saying that tech test I don't
Luca has a lot to say about that from
scum cast did um also um what you called
Marvel Ultimate Alliance low you know
probably picked it up you pick it up
yeah yeah you already know so we go get
it to that I've been doing that I wanna
shout blunt Jameson
you brought the family over lady Jameson
and the young lord lord harvey and we
actually tested out a lot of the
cooperative local co-op so that was kind
of the crappy version though I know it
is what kids see a joke on their face
your is it's just mind-blowing fits the
hands they'll hang I think that's what
it is
but yeah salute to that so we gonna do
the poll right quick before we get to
the topics in last week's poll results
are in and the people have spoken to the
question in regards to the gears 5
controversy involving the removal of
smoking as a narrative device how do you
feel about the decision moving forward
with the gears franchise
the winner at 64% of the latest IOP
three-way poll is that no non-issue
smoking doesn't affect gears 5 gameplay
it anyway group coming in at second and
only 25% was then not feeling it sets a
dangerous precedent and interferes with
dev artistic expression group and in
last place with only 11 percent of the
vote was the petit Lords I don't care
geez about to get smoked this holiday
without ad campaign footage digs oh I'm
just I'm just about to pay the bills cuz
dizzy you know his big shout out to i
dizzy anyone with the two dollars to
protect the people demand the knees sobs
oh no no when you throw that PlayStation
5 on and they tell you to play games
backwardly compatible
that'll be 3995 i want your knee sir
real quickly let's get beyond this OB
what about I don't know if we got a
chance to talk about the smoking issue
like what was your feeling on that whole
wheel smoked and removed from gears 5
and the pole I mean I it's not really a
big deal to me I didn't think there was
anything that really need to speak on I
think you know once it became public it
became just a bigger issue and a talking
piece you know I mean for for gamers and
and consumers but you know once rah got
out there and started speaking on it you
know bringing his dad into it and kind
of person miles and it it it made it a
bigger issue than it had to be I think
if they could have just you know made
mention of it and kind of moved on and
just removed it you know in a game
nobody would have noticed it anyway
because it was not ever a big thing it's
not like you know snake from Metal Gear
Solid or you know Kojima with the Matt
Mickelson thing you know how he said he
was gonna ask smoking just because he
saw him you know smoking off screen and
stuff like that so it was never anything
like that and it you know there's no
characters that you could even you know
click on how to and say like hey you
know that character was
or whatever so even know why they
brought it up in the first place if they
had never mentioned it no one would have
noticed and it would have been perfectly
fine they created all this drama and
controversy over nothing sometimes it
really is better to just shut up make it
better with you know I too was you know
against smoking from jump and my father
you know condolences obviously but it's
just kind of like why are you ringing of
your dead video game and smoking site
and prominent and gears relax well I
wanted them to do the finisher when they
smoke the whole smoking in the
cigarettes back I want shout out to
getting smoking back in video game oh no
doubt no doubt
oh get it we got a lot to discuss so uh
first of attack is actually not addicts
topic we gonna talk about these gears
five attack impressions test obviously
we know it dropped this week and it was
say concert if I know there was some
issue something had issues getting in
but um want to talk for the people who
actually played it and got a chance to
get in our home what's know a little
brat first I know you limited time as
well that's crap so one did you get a
chance to play cuz I saw you on my fee
say another champ on my footage you joke
I got real manager you were those guys
watch why'd you change your tactics take
know something I gotta try that Cognito
hug the corner turn around no you've had
me you've had a lot of conversations
offline and gear spas in general but now
that the tech test is out you I'm so
many bad chance but just what's your
overall depression so far I thought the
game runs very well I mean it's
impressive I mean that's 60 frames a
second I'm not gonna lie looks it looks
good it looks good I mean I was really
surprised I mean
cuz I heard Tech test I'll figure just
probably gonna be maybe some issues with
you know connecting the servers maybe
some framerate issues but once you got
in I mean it was smooth I was surprised
no it was silky smooth you still gotta
be nice for the shotty though yeah
playing you playing competitive
multiplayer you still got to be nice to
the shaadi the arcade was a nice welcome
addition I like that you know I felt
like that's a nice like segue for people
or entry point for people who maybe
haven't played a lot of multiplayer or
maybe might feel intimidated by it a
little bit because cuz gears if we take
something gears and I go back years one
to play multiplayer with Xbox Live clan
rogue nation that's this little group
and let me tell you some and a lot of
those guys when I used to play people
used to get mad if you sucked they would
let you know I mean it was oh and you
know and we had to deal with like lag
issues and so you got to make sure your
timing was right because you had a count
for lag and you had a count of all huh
the host advantage was serious but
serious yo shot let me just get into a
wreck quick shout out the gears for
putting up the ping test and exposing
your connection whoever's the worst ping
will be exposed in the gears 5 lobby
salute I saw people with like over a
hundred I'm at 27 I'm like I gotta get
out of this Lobby just not gonna try
1611 see them pings bro like okay I'm
not gonna get into details when what I
do but like when when I'm working in
networking and some of my networks when
we have connectivity issues there are
they are happening in certain countries
and I'm not going shout and you country
that that your internet is like you know
in the 1980s but
Wow the pain just to do a ping test and
you see it up in like the six seven
eight hundred she just like yeah okay
alright I know why I'm getting packet
loss here I see somebody's paying over a
thousand and I'm like I was out bouncing
I gotta go I can't play like this it's
not gonna be this is not gonna end well
for my team it's not gonna be good yeah
but uh it was it was a really good
experience I think the multi multi
player is gonna be solid I don't think
is any question about that the game
looks I think it looks I think looks
better than ding gears for I wouldn't
say it's like a generational leap but
it's definitely I think a little more
polished in terms of its visuals and
yeah man it's the multiplayer saw
everything there is rock-solid I I don't
have anything to complain about other
than know I really don't the only Lucas
shock that's fun
no only thing is is it left me wanting
campaign I want to see what the campaign
is gonna be love the guy was like and I
went back I downloaded the gears
Ultimate Edition and Gears war because I
want to go back to play those campaigns
and it left me think I said this to you
I was like why haven't they shown us
campaign like I really now I really want
to see it
let's get lady Luka in the realm house
you fill your chest touch that tech test
no I did not I was like now I'm good
I'll pass on it I'm not interested in
playing it and from what I've heard from
people I mean it looks just like yours
plus a lot of people weren't even able
to get in yeah good mess yeah I mean
like Enrique you said it looks like
gears just a little bit better
yeah just for you I mean like it look a
little bit better than gears for I think
what I've been saying for weeks now that
people bitching and complaining on
apologies cursing people people
complaining about not seeing the
campaign because apparently it supposed
to be completely and drastically
different from Gears for a lie
what you saw in the what's gonna be for
the campaign we have an idea of what the
campaign is so the whole thing is
terrible look they've always shown
campaign footage so I'm like well the
way they said they was rolling out this
one is they were showing you different
aspects of the game and leading up to
the last leg of the promo they was gonna
show you the campaign and people are
acting like they need to be part of the
PR department and and get stuff done no
let them roll game out how do you want
to roll it I think they're rolling it
out well they're gonna show you part of
the campaign right before the game is
about to launch and everybody's gonna be
all happy you gave me with at e3 and we
know that we felt it should have been
you know what I would do I don't work
for them absolutely no way I was doing a
little tech demo crap because I don't
believe a free labor a little beta and
I'm gonna tell you how I felt about I'm
giving you no information back home I
playing your game I'm not doing nothing
send me the real game and stop trying to
get me to work for you for free the
crunch plane is free labor game and then
you know what the problem is they don't
even say thank you for trying out our
game here's his $20 or you actually
worked
not four dollars looking you in your
eyes and they telling you thank you have
a nice day here the privilege of playing
neighbors we should get paid for doing
stress tests and betas you better why is
this a new thing a new concept we can
test that break and they're going to
Honolulu while you're driving to work
I think that's very possible
I do I need to go my god oh crap thank
you following us down brother yes I need
to get my niece the kindergarten home be
money and slow-mo did you guys get a
chance to play the guitar tech test yeah
I did but you know yeah I played
yesterday I didn't play yesterday
morning did a couple of matches I liked
it I mean I I I do I did say before how
I've been really like filling the arcade
mode too much but as far as performance
goes I got in mash is really fast it was
I had no frame rate drops game looks
does I agree with Enrica it does look
better than the foot getting gears for
but not like too much about it which I
mean the game came out three years just
just you know just me you just go good
if somebody was to ask you um no I want
you to try out
for me how much would you charge them
like a whole joy he was like you'll pack
Lawson I'm looking like about your ping
y'all are sitting here you're doing
things that they didn't even come up
with in their head and now right in the
deli yeah pack loss we got to work on
the pack once because slow mo said you
know and also the ping we got also keep
them grouped in an area are right okay
thank you slow mo and my question is how
much would you charge them would you
charge the beginning you said we logged
in early in the morning to place so what
time you do put it like four or five
hours no no no no I put it in maybe an
hour at the moon III and look I got
three kids in the morning anyway so it's
just like since I'm up you know already
fix breakfast let me go let me go
download this and give it a shot so look
I I feel you on your opinion I'm like
look I if I want this game to do well
and I understand they're working to the
sense that they make projections on how
many people they think are going to play
and then how how many servers and and
what adjustments they need to make to
make sure that at launch the game works
if if I get to enjoy playing a game a
little bit just for them to be able to
figure that out sooner
I'm all for perhaps a blessing I
wouldn't say all for the privilege of
playing the game Hey look I don't mind
playing technical test epic Wow
like I'm in the typical test with
bleeding edge you know and uh I I like
trying out stuff early so it was alright
it plays like typical gears game
multiplayer I think I think of the other
modes I think I think I think the gears
community alive them are like really
upset about some of the changes but when
it comes down to it when the game comes
out they're gonna play it be night it's
a lie though you see in a lot of
communities for different games you see
it does need it the vision
whatever people complain about changes
that they didn't really quite want and
then they can seem to keep playing the
game and they adjust and they adapt to
we do this with no no no it would be
money did you get you to get that out
gears v Texas burg oh for sure man for
sure you know I'm gear here so I had to
be there yeah I tried try to get in on
Friday it that was a no-go I'm gonna set
it down but I usually get up early
everyday so I was up early Saturday
morning and uh hopped in there played a
probably about two or three hours oh you
know I mean just gotta got in there got
my feet with it got an ardent 7550 got
an ER and got my feet wet cuz I haven't
played gears for in quite a while like a
lot of my friends dropped off and you
know I mean when you play gears you you
kind of want to play with some friends
you can't play the game with everybody
so getting back in there getting arcade
mode you know it's some different you
know for for gears franchise is you know
wasn't something I was really expecting
yeah because like each character kind of
has like their own type of load out and
then you know gun guns are upgraded over
time or whatever which I didn't really
understand I had to kind of try to
figure that out
you know whatever how many modes do they
have since I'm you know didn't play know
what they had available to the public
there's our camo and then they got the
ranked mode with escalation and can get
a hit out the attic laughs from the ER I
should be home in 30 minutes they sent
me home with meds so slow-mo you and I
can continue you keep trying to repeat
something right this is what she does
she goes hey everyone didn't-didn't
slow-mo just taking a look a nail
you need a real eye
I said if you ask what was the what was
the battle about is right so you know
we're talking about this year's tech
test yesterday and everyone on my panel
seemed pretty negative and down on it
including slow-mo interesting how he
changed his tune
so everyone seemed pretty down on it and
Lord addict was in the chat oh you guys
are all row what did you do you know
like just crying about something or not
in here because I would be entertaining
for me so you know I since linked and
him in slow mo started going back and
forth it's almost like well you said
this to me and addicts like so how do
you know I was talking to you did I say
your name and something like well I mean
what you talked about the assumption I
was talking to you and I said because
what you were applying to is what I was
saying really foxy was saying the same
thing
all right I guess all okay I just
because I'm really super confused right
wait wait what is transpiring right now
one camp was on the side of the detect
demo sucked on a tech demo was lukewarm
and then the other camp was on the side
of the tech demo was pretty good too
great or something what happened was
people were talking about its issues
more than how they enjoyed it okay yeah
they got a chance to play some free
stuff any complaining saying why are you
guys complaining and then my panel was
like well they want us to tell them
what's wrong with this that's why
they're doing it oh you know what and I
feel this is this is that my whole crux
oh pay me if you want my opinion crux is
don't don't give me no free stuff and
then tell me how it tastes
taste is free if I pay for it then fine
if you if you gave me some money and you
want my opinion then that's something
different now you put it out there for
free and you think I'm supposed to be
all happy and all yeah they know you
guys love gears you got guys outdated
with tattoos on a butts they guys I saw
it all I swear we saw the videos we saw
the behind the scenes and I love the
fact how feverish these guys are but
they've taken advantage of your fandom
and your love I gotta I gotta I gotta
shoot a shadow forward here's the
question I feel where you're going in
reference to the whole free labor thing
I do understand your point my question
is No
aren't we the same gamers that when a
game come out and is broken at launch we
do like hi marketing get the marketing
team together right and start allocating
these bucks to do the situation now this
is the only way I say you fix this for
me
alright I play your game if I play at a
certain point the in-game currency to
skin credits so berries like some games
do that yeah I've seen that happen like
like I can't remember the last time that
happened but I remember some games
giving you like in game in game like
cosmetics and stuff like that like her
fur you know playing yeah right no I
feel exactly what you're saying Luca
right but when is a point where you
break in a line of taking advantage of
people and and not compensating them for
their loyalty in their time because
these guys are feverishly loyal I'm not
saying I'm not taking anything away from
it I'm just doing it on a moral
standpoint that I see a tech demo up or
beta I'm not in for it right you know
that right I don't you're not gonna get
that information from me but you will
get your game is broken and you need to
go take it and fix it if you didn't
allocate funds to the mark and the team
I get that I just I the only thing that
we're on different side of the fence is
there's no way that to really replicate
millions of people at some point you
have to open up the doors and say yo
come inside check it out if it ain't
what it is let us know or whatever but
it's just a matter of how you handle it
right that's right everybody the free
market one skin but you gotta see it
from the other way to it for somebody
who's on the fence if you get a chance
to try it and it's not for you then you
didn't spend the money on it and suppose
somebody day one goes and buys is all
excited and it's broken and it you know
disaster I was like this week right how
many people weren't left after that was
I now
I mean for me I didn't I'd only thing I
care about when it comes to pain and
hoard I like hoard everything else a
good you play with others ok great
straighten the bushes for me no listen
shouts everybody I agree everybody round
table I think like qoodles off the back
like when I first started it like they
had the adaptive control to support I
thought that was really cool and I'm
saying the HDR looks fantastic that 4k
60 good lure like I was really impressed
now full disclosure mmm I despise gears
multi-play like really heavy in my
history with gears multiplayer is like
it's in the bushes either rolling
shotgun stuff it's never been my thing
but I can't front is something about
this new joint I don't know what it is
be if they tweaked the movement the
movement and they took they tweaked they
tweaked the weapons like all the a lot
of guns are more automatic and it's our
gun it way more lethal and what I felt
was the time to kill on the other
weapons because normally it's shotgun
roll shotgun roll I don't like I had a
shot like the time to kill was increased
I mean lowered so that I can actually
kill people that from afar as opposed to
relying on the shotgun all the time like
you know I like this again like that new
giant would you snatch it do it over to
cover like like that joint ours our
finish it felt good it fell front I'll
never play multi but I can't front this
is the first time I'm like yo I might
play I probably played a Mozart is here
like it is cool so shout out to them on
that we talked about the ping joy I
thought that was interesting and then on
as far as the tutorial I thought that
was dope just like you know with the
beer talking to you and all that like it
felt like classic gear so it gave me
hope or like Yoda kick cuz I felt like
it was veritably done well the armed a
little the tutorial so I actually gave
hope that the campaign is actually gonna
be good and then to the thing I've said
I don't know if it was all as brat
before he left but on the whole like
talk you I'm you know what I'm risking
remember like the old xbox 360 OG xbox
you get a lot and then it be the post
carnage mats right I did somebody
talking that you know you can get a
chance to talking again before as well
it was some dude in a few don't have not
before okay a joint and we're excellent
some teams and sometimes like yeah 17
III we smoke them dudes there's no stop
man and people in report I'm scared in
that part you know if we can get back to
a point where we actually game and have
fun we can talk much to each other
because I'm all about that talking mess
because if they can hear what I'm saying
when I'm playing destiny iron banner and
you can hear what I'm saying to you
while I'm gonna fire board on your way
shoot meaning it I want you to
understand you banned me just the last
question I was my ass if I saw in Lucca
in reference to the the raw Ferguson
situation we know you had to tweet out
and he kind of talked about hey you know
he actually stretched that yo this was a
tech test and not so it's like I want to
bring this to y'all real quick about the
whole thing with stress test versus demo
and then the obviously said things
didn't go as well as they would hold but
as a result that this should make it
better it's you know September when it
drops like what are you to feel about
that I'll go first
Luka I don't feel anything about it if
you know you have an idea what kind of
what what kind of issues people are
gonna have trying to get it right as you
scale this up as more and more people
try to get in I would think you get out
in front of it before it actually
happens because this is not the first
thing the first time you do this so and
and stress this to people because you
know people people like to talk smack
you know any time you play especially a
Microsoft product if
you come out there with something subpar
something that's not working the eyes of
the internet will be on you just get up
get up in front of it and just say it
before it actually happens and I just
had a feeling they were hoping that it
wouldn't happen and it did happen and
they had to get out in front of it to
sort of quell Timor who were flipping
out it's just it I get well Lucas ain't
like it's just not a big deal it's not a
thing but you know it's gonna happen get
out in front of it cuz you know how
people are my god I gotta go at this
little muchif Oochie Oochie fufufu then
I'm gonna acknowledge Meucci fuchi for
fufu listen listen Moochie fuchi for
fufu I'm gonna let you know something
maybe it might launch broken but at some
point in time you got to realize that if
you play game pass you pay one buck and
you get the ultimate edition you played
it for days ahead of time you can in an
equivalent on what everything that
you're repping because I don't know if
you're repping Sony I don't know if
you're repping world you can get it on
the PC so you got to be rapper in one
person right so you can sit there your
feelings talking about impending doom is
gonna launch broken but if you didn't
pay anything but a dollar for you you
have nobody to cry to all right so I
would like for you to start with the
trolling but you know what and this is
the only time I'm going to acknowledge
you I want you to put it in colors from
you try wouldn't want me to read what
you're saying because right now I'm
actively blacking you out but I want you
to put it in color so I can read it and
then you call that man one thing I do
kind of feel like and this is more of a
suggestion I think I'm gonna comes our
cable in the two matches that day they
were both arcade I didn't like how you
couldn't just choose why you couldn't
get any weapon that's in on the mat like
to be in the packs like you'll find like
a weapon in the scenario right
whatever and you kind of like you build
up points and then you get it like I
didn't realize that as I was playing
only did two matches and I was just like
you're where's the shotgun at right you
know like I think if they I think they
did that kind of shot you know keep the
whole shotgun meta thing to a manual but
I think buffing weapons and they have
made adjustments to weapons which is
good but I think buffing weapons and not
necessarily removing the ability to
start with a particular weapon isn't the
right way to go so just just something
that I you know I'm my opinion and I
know is that's just arcade mode but
still if that's what a lot of casuals we
want to play man you're gonna get a lot
of people using that mode right and then
I much rather see em do like a loadout
instead like where you could right now
if you gonna play arcade mode then let
me choose my my own weapons and let me
go in you know I mean all the base
weapons anyway like all the weapons at
that are available and then you know at
the shotgun in there and then exactly
that I mean that's where I am with it
yeah yeah it'll allow in the last
question in reference to the whole cross
play for my understanding with PC you
know is it like in arcade mode but not
in comp or something like that I'm
hearing rumblings about that move to
anybody I experienced it it's in arcade
mode and it doesn't give you option to
turn it off alright and then and then
when you go to the ranked mode it'll ask
you you know if you if you like to you
know play with PC players or you know
console verse PC so that that is gonna
be interesting to see if you know once
the game launches if Arcade Mode doesn't
give you that option or not does it have
my keyboard support for the Xbox I'm not
sure I'm not sure but I would assume
that it probably would you know wants to
launches since that is a feature yes
interesting to see how they gonna hear
later I think this is a huge advantage
yeah but that's all I got listen I got
anything else for Gears 5 but uh we go
get into this other game exclusive that
dropped on the switch three three as I
create a collective groans from lower
King
[Laughter]
drop today so for those who got a chance
but let's just start with that or less I
saw did you get a chance to pick of
course I told you I was excited about
this first time ever I get a chair to
talk to you much and then oh right
actually play it um so let me first go
solve with the negative stuff that I
kind of saw it
um I think when compare I like the art
style right I think it's I think it
suits it it's a very comic book art
style unlike the first two which is more
realistic um but at the same time I do
think it's still in some ways kind of
looks worse only we look at the detail
and in the older games and some of the
um some of the set pieces I just sort of
think this when you say a 360 game looks
bit off switch you say but I do sort of
think in some instances I felt that some
of the yeah some of the environments are
set pieces in three felt kind of bland
like lacking textures and stuff like
lacking depth um also let me see what
else oh the camera the camera helps for
me because this is part of the reason
why I didn't like the other one so much
but see back then now I don't really
care so much but I had an issue with
isometric games like I didn't want to
play though so it bothered me so the
fact that this has a heroic camera it
kind of helps me think that it's you
know third-person over-the-shoulder game
sometimes I enjoy that but just the fact
that the cameras are very smart you
basically have to maneuver it everywhere
it's not it's not intuitive at all in
terms of turning corners and things like
that so that can be a little bit
obtrusive but that said the game itself
I think the fact that they made it
they've gotta simplify the RPG mechanics
but at the same time made them sort of
deeper but you just it's kind of like
Mass Effect 2
where they sort of took some of that out
of your hands for a Marvel game that
they're trying to make appeal to
everybody especially all fans of those
other series and probably bringing in
younger new players I think it does a
great job I think the lineup is it's
huge and his Akoni content gonna
continue to grow
I'm so I'm enjoying it I really have I'm
demantoid oh whoa I know you picked it
up so we got a lot to discuss okay man
what's your feeling Marvel Ultimate
Alliance three out in stores now I don't
know how far I am in it right now I'm
thinking I'm probably about halfway
through but I'm really enjoying it like
as a sawed-off said that mix of
characters is great there there I mean
like I just got Ghost Rider a little a
little while ago just got Doctor Strange
as well and it's just like somebody's
characters just like oh yeah like I'm
really enjoying that I do agree about
the camera there are times where like
you're fighting and then the camera will
just change to like almost like is your
character and you can see the train the
gaining is fun to play hours are great
the the the combos that you can do that
they have like combos we're like two
characters where there
these really work together later Captain
America and his shield and Iron Man with
the with his beams you can combine those
to do the do combo hits as well as their
supers like being able to like when you
get all your supers ready and then just
hitting both left and right bumper and
chain reaction is dodging
but I would say like as far as the
visuals yeah I was like look I knew was
gonna look dated because I knew what
they were trying to go with they were
trying to hear pretty and pretty much
emulate the older games came out like
the last one was like 20 2006 but I
still was somewhat disappointed even
though I knew what they were going at
like I'm thinking like do you not have
enough memory to make these environments
look a little bit less bland it's just
like a lot of them are just like big set
stage area for a fight and then hallway
hallway hallway hallway it's just like
it didn't seem like except for the
x-mansion the x-mansion looked like what
I expect
but everything else seems very just
generic and so but like I said I always
play for the story how is the story
stories very good
I want the chat to understand I'm buying
this game I'm waiting for my negro bucks
to come in oh I'm buying the game this
this is no lie I'm not gonna say hair
fraud you guys you know make fun of the
game you don't buy it because I played
one and two I'm just interested I'm just
this is just jokes be honest with you I
don't really expect too much from my
switch my switch is doing as best as it
can how he can
so um I just you know my I'm actively
trolling guys so overall I sava hey you
talkin to ya I like the story but I was
a little disappointed it was kind of you
know another take on the infinity story
like what it was mini come on you want
something in our topics you see at the
end it says new updated switch I'm going
to address exactly what you talked about
mummy it's a date you wanna fire mommy
so we are supposed to be team and you
out here actively slandering my heart
right now
always finish somewhere I like the game
with you up next week I need to hear I
think it's a positive reinforcement oh
man I'm really enjoying the game you
Tommy especially Pete I threw it in
there Friday night you know what once
gears wasn't working was not working
they wouldn't let me in they had the
doors closed my toe one speck of g-money
I know because he just actively
witnessed something ask a question
it has local co-op or has online co-op
we had both name is Bobo
yes okay we did for people in know just
just to be week it's four four four four
people yes how's the lag on
okay I gotta put a fraud on myself
because I was looking for holes I'm
having a great time with the game you
know I mean like like the guy said
there's there's some few complaints
there I think visually it could have
looked better
you know I may not think that the
cinematics and some of the stuff that
they have look great
but then when you look at the game it's
like uh you know man it's it's not as
sharp as you would like it to be you
know I mean it's it's definitely got
yeah it's definitely got like some
little Jags and stuff that you notice
you know man just looking throughout the
vironment and stuff like that so I
definitely wish it could have looked
better and and the camera angle dish
definitely can become a headache over
time you know I mean you get in some of
these big fight scenes and the cameras
like right on your neck I mean you can't
see nothing that's going on so but other
than that I'm having a great time with
it man it's good to see like all these
characters you know in a game like this
and and for Nintendo to go out there and
throw some money at it you know I mean
you got a salute what a way dragon be a
pay can you check the game though but yo
real quick the last one I played I know
Luka is crying on this day she's muted
her bike for the sole subject but oh
yeah I'm loving it maybe it is umpire
solve your zip but it's just like Marvel
ultimate last one was one of my favorite
games too was okay but one had the
bigger roster and I felt a better story
did to it
okay it's like a comic book story like
then what I like about it is is so much
cinematics I didn't think there would be
so much cinematics they got the little
you don't saying like feel of less
watching a comic book and I'm saying and
then like this just cell shaded right no
I graphically last a Capcom game
fighting game prima is it the odd
direction just like that because when I
was looking at videos of it it looked
like it was in the vein of that cartoony
musculature on the characters it wasn't
too much detail in it but it was enough
that you get cross like the costumes and
stuff like that
you mean like Ultimate Alliance - no no
I'm sorry yeah because I've really liked
that game and I really like the
storyline and stuff like that to it and
when I saw the Marvel Alliance when I
saw I was like okay they kind of took
some cues from their art direction and
applied it to this I just want to know
if it was in the same vein because I
like the you know the cartoony nature of
it I'm glad that they switch from the
realistic Club and Lloyd Jamie program
but Lloyd Jameson in the belly shout the
hey we brought the family over got a
chance to test it like I said in a
four-player co-op Shahab he definitely
loved it you don't say it's simple easy
to get in what I like this he was
playing with his son and what happened
is you know how most games is like this
is cool thing about switching mama lines
in general is that you can play with
someone who's inexperienced and then
like they got that feature if like say
two three I go ahead like it'll drag the
fourth person it's cooler it's a
love-letter if you're a fan of Marvel
Ultimate Alliance one this is a love
letter to them after a team ninja I love
the art style you know I'm saying they
got the old-school feel again is it
gonna appeal to everybody no is there
some camera issues absolutely
you don't tell but as far as that
Saturday morning cartoon feel with and
you know affinity Gauntlet storyline
with all these characters and little
deal we talked about
slo-mo we can Colossus in on Cyclops
free right nights with now bleh shot the
monster alley you know as a man exactly
you know say so we get in all this
content as an exclusive and teenagers
that's all I got on it you know Sam but
I definitely definitely feel like I said
it was a good low exclusive for them and
it fits the switch ecosystem unlike soft
comments going
okay you gotta think that Nintendo you
know we'll use this in capitalize on it
and and we'll see a autumn Alliance for
you know me sometime tomorrow I want to
get it's been over a bit like it's been
about 13 years
super scoop that was a shout to them for
supporting any luck is gonna be around
so that's that we gonna move on
hopefully a lady look you have magnetic
that the traitor Lord sovereign to
switch topics out out a friend to the
realm Lord Matt piscatella so this past
week in honor of Comic Con he oh yeah
and announced that uh Marvel's
spider-man for ps4 had surpassed Batman
Arkham City as the best-selling
superhero old all-time so shout out to
insomniac and that's his friend just
gotta give it up to this be money
victory lap I was on a research and be
money yeah we had member that discussion
be right well firm I got you and King
held so firm but I gotta give you two
the only to our students right now yeah
I don't want to stay in the power and I
was like okay how's that the guy shot
them up this is day victory that mom
glad he
that is an achievement that are super
impressive that it can take out a Batman
game that's been out since 2011 right
and this is one thing I was looking up
and I couldn't find the specific
information is this just the initial
launch of the game on 360 ps3 and pc or
it doesn't include all the other
iterations of the package ones the
remaster I looked up that information I
couldn't find it so regardless to what
is still a very impressive feat for an
exclusive game to one platform to defeat
a third party game after so many years
market it is impressive so I big shout
out to spider-man is it was amazing Game
one of the few games that I Platinum
loved that game no my only beef with
only issue is that of course the
internet gets ahold of this and I might
advocate you know and there's some some
people on the Internet ponies we like to
call but they'd like they took this
information as ammunition for the
argument about how exclusives really
really matter to the ecosystem of a
first party right and how much they
actually matter because I've always
argued that they matter in terms of
creating an identity but at the end of
the day once the hardcore purchase is
particularly the exclusives you don't
really see you know as particularly
PlayStation PlayStation have over 100
million consoles out there you don't see
that you know even with spider-man was
such an amazing selling game you have
about 10 million sale something like
that
so I always wondered what why isn't it
selling more so many consoles out there
right now so I've always argued that
they're there they're important to the
identity of the system but not
necessarily to the long-term success as
much as you know in this day and age
living games like a destiny you know
fortnight obviously stuff like that
these are these are things that the
casuals are playing and after those
first 10 million 12 million sales of
consoles
it's the casuals that are buying these
consoles so I just didn't like the fact
that some people jumped on the
spider-man BAM
to sort of reinforce this idea that all
exclusives are what make a consul period
because my Dominican special cakes right
Piderman isn't like talk to me when
Nathan Drake is selling those numbers
right spider-man is a special case so I
just wonder what you guys feel about
that am I am I am i off here or you guys
agree because I think again regardless
of what it's an amazing achievement but
it is I don't man oh okay so you go
let's get slow in first let's get slow
at first cuz I'm obviously when the news
came out slow like what did you feel
like the greatest selling superhero game
of all time and it's a soft point you
know is this overblown as far as the the
weighted vert value of it exclusive like
where you at with it well I first I
would say I thought was vindication
because I remember last year and you
guys mentioned MOOCs I remember MOOCs
coming on brat saying oh man that Spider
Man wasn't gonna outsell God of War we
were like saying like yo it's spider-man
and this game looks good like this game
looks like it's gonna be the best father
man game that was ever made you you can
you combine that with Sony's marketing
and then you you're getting like I mean
who thought of a New York subway think
about that that train that train like
all paid out in spider-man I mean stuff
like that is just outside the box
marketing and it got and in two solves
point yeah this is although this is a
this is an exclusive it's it's
spider-man transcends gaming he's a huge
iconic comic he's a huge icon on
cartoons growing up for us like we grew
up on spider-man
you know cartoons in the movies he was
one like he I used to have before dark
night and MCU this movie was like the
best the best quality superhero movies
you would see so there's generations
upon generations of people out there
where they go to the movies or cartoons
or whatever
who know who he is and if you own that
system
you got think you're gonna get the game
it is what it is like so I mean do in
comparison to the other spider-man games
have come out smashed it
Oh smash it because it's a better game
than those other games well I want to
say that you know I typically tend to
ignore the people on Twitter and YouTube
and not watch the videos because I don't
care enough to do so however I would
like to point out we're talking about
the ponies what about the Xbox who spent
months upon months upon moms before the
game was released saying let's just
murder spy drinking it's not gonna go
well at all I tend to ignore them to you
right yes annoying so and to be fair
like when I talk about like you gotta
warm it so 10 million copies uncharted
it's probably like up over 15 million
but we're talking about in in a year's
time less than a year's time this game
is surpassed how many tales like
probably at 10 million now it's kind of
insane it's insane but and in2 me that's
that's the spider-man effect it isn't
again god of war and ease in these other
games will sell well over the entire
life tell me something guys what do you
think this is attributed to because it
is I mean it's kind of bonkers when you
think about it this Batman has been out
since 2011 it was widely regarded as an
amazing game especially it was really
you know what it is like when Arkham
Asylum came out everybody did people
love they know like it kicked off this
the surge of good video games right a
good superhero video games and usually
the game that kicks it off doesn't
necessarily benefit from it I think
Arkham Asylum the city did to consider
that in eight years since its launch it
still surpassed by this game like what
do you think it's attributed to mostly
because you know I mean similar to what
they did with that
it was only placed on one studio so if
you look at a lot of those old
spider-man games there's a bunch of
different developers who touched those
games and they were never of high
quality yeah I mean Activision was
publishing a lot of those games and they
got you know some no-name studios come
out there and put together a little
arcade style you know move on ranked
game or movie port you know I mean and
none of those games were really that
great and I think yeah when you and that
the IP off to somebody who's talented
you know I mean just like you know they
did with Batman and giving into
Rocksteady and Rocksteady has really
built up their their studio and and
we've got high expectations you know for
them yeah I mean in the next game so
when you give a game like this to
insomniac who's had a great track record
you know I mean I put out some some
really you know great gangs you have
high expectations and they and they
delivered on that yeah I think in a lot
of ways I think gaming especially when
you think about when when our chemists
Arkham City came out it kind of
parallels what happened with you know
superhero movies whereas there was that
one movie that sort of convinced
everybody that this could be done in a
way that was respectful to the UH the
source material and made and interesting
and of course can make money for you and
I think the same sort of thing happened
where it's like the gaming landscape
when this game came out was different
than it is today
mm-hmm I think the fact that you have
you know whatever more casuals and
purchasing consoles today than they did
back in 2011 and I think also helps a
lot when you see a property like
spider-man
regardless to what any kid see
spider-man he's gonna want whatever that
is right but also I want to jump a shot
the victims Dean in a chat I mean
elephant on the room to us we can't
ignore the success at MCU also right I
mean it's such a juggernaut right now
what sorry continue kick my points get
your victory you and be money yeah first
first and foremost I told you it was
gonna smash every game that came before
you did I told you you didn't understand
what was going to happen
mm-hmm if you got a Playstation there's
only two games for you to buy a
Playstation 4 to be honest did that you
have to have
for PlayStation 4 like you have that you
have to play these games in our
generation you have to play spider-man
you have to play God of War yes those
are two games I don't care I don't I
don't care how you gain mm-hmm you gotta
play those two games now I'm not a god
of warfare with me saying that but the
technical aspect of that game was great
so it was phenomenal mm-hmm um but this
game this little guy right here I knew
it was going to do what it did because
one you had one great studio as be money
pointed out mm-hmm um the MCU as kinda
came in and took my it was definitely in
full swing Sony's marketing um push that
they put behind it was fantastic thanks
Alma mm-hmm
all of that wrapped into a phenomenal
story of amateur spider-man it wasn't a
child spider-man because we got that in
MCU so what you're getting now is you're
giving because it tackled a lot of adult
topics when you use like what
spider-man's a deadbeat daddy all right
what the hell is going on here and I
thought that the dlc was implemented
greatly uh you know a lot of people went
at me on it i don't care what you feel
sometimes you want to get the dlc at one
point but i want you to have enough time
to grieve the game through then get the
dlc to get the residual income coming in
because you know it's not a persistent
world for the cell numbers the way that
it just did other than how destiny does
destiny milk's you all day you're
persistently playing and engagement
spider-man has one time to pull you in
and to see if you're gonna like the
world and the fact that the controls is
fantastic the graphics is incredible the
soundtrack is amazing the the gameplay
is outstanding all that came together
and made this spectacular game and
people are still buying it like if
you've got a PlayStation now I'm pretty
sure that you're running out to buy this
or got a war
so for the numbers to show that it blew
out past superhero game Russian in the
chat you know ain't got no color is he
going there oh man was easy even on
ultimate difficulty said Batman least
made you use your brain so okay so
you're saying to me now what makes a
great game for you is that it bashes
just skull up against the wall that's
that's a great game good play the dark
soul games of the game doesn't have
anything to do with it selling well so
it's not even relevant to the
conversation like you can have your
preference you can enjoy Batman more but
this isn't you know when maybe money was
talking about it question let me just
stop before sex is for being you cuz you
guys again sort of vision I envisioned
it before everybody at the point when
God of War came out right not understand
what God was doing out here right
mmm-hmm
Ottawa was it's just seemed like that in
surrounding is beating and you know we
wanted won the war for you know video
games yeah all that stuff and it said I
kind of gain so it's at the height of
this thing we know spiders coming and
all that but not only despite a man beat
that we're talking about every superhero
game before that like that part of it
like the magnitude of debt like can you
even envision that happening like that
to me
spider-man's the number one Marvel
superhero above everybody else he's the
most popular superhero he's loved by
kids and adults you know I mean and kids
don't even need to know anything about
spider-man you take a kid to a store and
they see spider-man just a red and blue
pops no I mean and they get excited
about it so you know I mean just just
that alone what I knew was gonna help
repeal it you know I mean because when
you when you look at Batman and you look
at all the other superhero games you
know I mean they're cool and and they
may not appeal to
two kids so mean I mean that they don't
appeal to everyone
yeah I mean some people are totally
against DC don't care nothing about DC
and they're all Marvel heads or over
ever
and some people are told against Marvel
and all DC heads but when you talk about
spider-man he's generally loved by
everybody yeah and and you can see that
just with ourselves that they had of
this game and any anything else look at
what the spider-man into the spider
versus movie did for them in December
you know I mean that that was crazily
you know successful for for Sony and
what they did with the spider-man brand
and look at you know just the vitamin we
that just came out you know I mean so
they say really have that popularity you
know which part minute and people are
super excited about spider-man and where
it's kind of go in the future so mostly
being petty Superman 110 to 64 that fire
that that game was gonna be exactly what
it turned out to be when they showed the
trailer right and it was in and that was
actual gameplay said my man if that game
looks like that right there I was
actively hunting for them in the
PlayStation Pro spider-man edition and
so they got ridiculous with the prices I
was like I got a wallet but if I was
able to get my hands on that shout-out
to miss text so fancy that got it and
put it on Twitter and was trolling
everybody in the world about it but um I
really wanted it so bad I thought that
that game from that aspect to be actual
gameplay actual in game engine and its
translate that across because listen got
a war slow this game is moving a mile a
minute and every time and and you have
to be in pure control of it and I and I
love it because you know dr. wall goes
to room to room
Claire these enemies out in this room
then go to the next room clay these
enemies out in this room go to the next
one
spider-man anywhere anytime I'm taking a
book bags for no reason I'm jumping on
people cars for no reason I'm
showing people in the street when I got
to the street level and saw the NPCs
looking honey look I said this is the
game of the generation not that dad read
their Redemption crap this generation
here we go
80 who starts off you want to wrap this
up oh man I just think I think it's a
great achievement I think again the fact
that I do is able to beat out in an
eight-year-old game that's been on the
market forever that's universally are
loved as well is amazing and I can't
wait for the sequel no doubt yeah me too
yeah absolutely a tremendous achievement
Spidey in the building you have I told
you all right that's a whole Channel
five take that's what we would say when
people win but they didn't win blood in
your snow I knew when this which many
thing was released gonna be released the
Nintendo will somehow come to its market
to the bushes and they did just what I
got now guys it's a new updated switch
here hey check it out and it's $2.99 and
you know what it has has Rumble it has
joy cons and it has doubled the damn
battery life my man like what is the
sense of a portable that's really not as
portable as the real switch will the
real switch please stand down
let's get some context we understand you
know say I'll jump in real quick cuz I
got it I got I know is I was asking this
is very interesting to me because at the
end of the day we just sort of switch
light announced right we just right now
you know everyone yeah okay Court is an
excitement low for it and then when you
go to the actual advertising a
comparison page between a switch light
and the switch I was checking out this
page and I've seen this before then I
scroll like a couple days ago and it's
like you secretly see they added digital
switching magically has better battery
life and storage the nine hours so I'm
just like double Luca I felt that way
cuz of like how you not gonna advertise
this and then you just like secretly you
know stealth drop this system you trying
to sell this language so I want to bring
it to y'all like is this you know shady
practices my great apartment Nintendo's
always doing some some spooky stuff man
what a surprise nothing they do ever
makes any sense to me like things that
shouldn't work works for them so you
know I don't know man it's Nintendo I
have zero interest in that trash it's I
would say I'm shocked but I'm not I'm
absolutely not shocked it's weird to me
look I've never seen it's really no a
photographer's crazy but I won't guess
okay so this is this is what they do
right because this is the dropped
inferior model right for the kids or
whatever this what it is improve the
base model right then whenever next year
when they announced a pro version right
now mind you the pro version isn't gonna
have the enhanced battery holder before
second are we sure that this is that the
to be the pro version now the same yeah
something else I don't wanna cut you and
let you know that there's no enhance
battery for a new one yeah this this is
not any hands bad no is the enhanced
chipset though he said in his chip but
they say chuckle up to nine hours on a
product page they're talking about up to
now
they literally offered it in a super
battery life and all right so currently
for the switch the original one is
approximately two to five it's gonna be
a facto new battery model H AC zero zero
one is the new one right and that one is
approximately four to five to nine hours
right that is like hold on a sec I got a
pigtails
stitch my flamethrower already you're on
shout out to going to switch out his
switch at Best Buy using the war you
know the best buy hustle you all what
was that what was that I didn't see
anything pop up to something pop up like
to me this is the thing no right they're
gonna improve this is gonna be the new
base model the switch right once they
get rid of that old stock that all the
ones gonna have this new battery now
when they do announce the new switch
would it improve GPU capability whatever
the case may be that battery life is
gonna be negated mmm because they're
gonna tell you you could be the
additional horsepower behind the machine
just put you right back at that three to
five hours you open here you know it's
the truth it's just the truth
you know is did we already know that
many is helping up fly off the shelf man
put wings on imagine
let's ask Google with MPD ferocity but
what about about the real talk about
this whole switch do you think this is
the pro do you feel this is a sneaky
move by Nintendo to drop this like where
you at with this improved switch with a
better chipset and more storage this is
definitely not the pro mmm this is
definitely the product just on a
announcer Pro it'll be some sort of
Excel version or some some other
nonsense that Nintendo always comes up
with with their name but you know this
is just a Tendo hitting us with the you
know little sneak attack won't got
everybody out there spent a $300 we got
the junkie version a few years later you
know I mean they came out an improved
version and unless you go and go out
there and spend your bucks that's what
you stuck with the junkie so we got a
rock out with it unless we do like salty
said and go take it back and switch it
on our Best Buy warranty so switch gang
are we copying - all we copying this
improved version include join man you
know we come over the games man you
can't do not it the many might be for
like my daughter so oh you know I got
the og one you know I mean so if I get
to improve battery one out I don't need
them in I'm gonna buy the new one with
the great battery you know give my son
you know the old coalition
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
so regular switch has trouble playing
current games how is the switch mini
gonna handle those game you know what I
said that last week a matter of fact the
stitches so on it
he definitely pointed out the fact that
what happens when a mini tries to do
that super colossal thing that y'all's
talking about in Marvel Alliance eighty
game of the ten dollars in the chat how
do you all feel about the rumor that
there will be a home console only
version of a switch because they
couldn't get the pro version because the
ps4 base power levels are high and how
powerful should it be so a pro version
home cut a console only JD
let me tell you something you onto
something better you know take it
sometimes like when we go to like packs
and we go to e3 if that was actually the
only guy out there you know playing this
which involve all my life these dupes so
I only would ever know but I would
actually purchase that like I will
purchase a home only pro system for
Nintendo if it's priced accordingly all
right no doubt so slow as you would say
like what do you feel man do you think
this is sneaky by Nintendo is this all
pro like where you have with all this
but it
looking nice but which is why I have no
no sympathy for Nintendo when I go to
Best Buy and I say you look Michael
Collins is my joy Curran is drifting
drifting on the Tokyo Drift on me my
screen is washed out yeah I'm gonna need
I'm gonna need to switch this out Matt
that window right over there I'm gonna
go right there oh we might have to get
that Best Buy Partnership go I tell you
right because I brought this bad boy
back and saved you exactly you Best Buy
got the best warranty out there like I
bought mine they were like hey you know
you want that yes yes I want that oh
well he could finish the sentence I want
that don't want that warrants you
prepare always support best buys
warranties because when my pc power unit
went out I went and I was like well here
you go he said well we don't um do power
units when he gets me a cart and said
here's $5,000 the same price that I paid
for that PC was on that car and I went
in the back to buy a new PC I thought I
was robbing my controller when the
rubber grips was coming off my Lee and I
he was like yo you got the words here
and I'm like yeah he was like yeah just
literal you going in I ain't even I said
yeah cause warranties are so late and
every time I go in because I've had to
replace my elite controller twice I
always get the same okay ready
oh yeah we're having that tradin oh yeah
you can know you can hear when I first
got my elite I had to trade in one of my
controllers to get it for 125 she's like
you can keep the controller why oh let
me tell you something every single year
you're gonna come in and replace your
warranty and get a new elite every
[Laughter]
I'm writing this all down right now
thank you all for this best Lord
everybody else's wrap up with the this
way like woah yeah yeah I mean look the
mini I'm getting that for my son and and
to kind of to something that a king
brought up like you know like what
what's the purpose of the many for me I
mean it's not going to be for me I'm not
gonna play it but I was like my son
wants to switch but I don't quite trust
him where he is right now he's man I
don't quite trust him with his his his
toys his product he gonna lose her joy
calm within a week you don't get from
that that deadlight right yeah I'm
giving that light where the joy cons
don't come off so you can't lose that
from rough-and-tumble kids but to
justify the the price I just really
couldn't come to grips with the just
$100 off I just really couldn't do it
then when the new information that came
out yeah basically shut your hole Lego
you could have took this information and
wait at least until after the mini came
out and then did this but you actively
for anybody that has any type of sneak
to them when today page I wouldn't know
it upset me I was like I would have
never known it and now I'm gonna say
well Kings like I'm thank the many the
like might be around like I need the
battery life I think that to me is more
important than anything up the better
CPU the better battery life you know I'm
saying on web
I think that um they still gonna come
out with a pro actually don't mind that
this is not the pro and that they do
come out with an eventual pro because
let's be real when next gen start and
Scarlett and PS 5 is out here the switch
games gonna look even more dated right
so at the end of the day I think that's
when they need to prep a pro or Excel
whatever version they call during the
next gen guys overheats on and then
eventually you know that this chipset
and battery life and it's eventually
it'll be implemented into the light this
is not the only iteration of the light
we're getting the BS wiper stop swiping
we are whole episode of Dora Explorer we
know he's gonna say this guy actively
trying to swipe our wallets we are
condoning this behavior why are
demonized Marlin if everyone gives
Nintendo a pass for some reason it's
really a big smile on their face with a
big fat mustache plumber nobody else
nobody's gonna have those that type of
feeling for Nathan you know everybody
got that relative that do foul stuff all
think they're gonna increase the
durability of the many for many people
who will because they could just you
know JD game or yes they have to I think
that's really the purpose of the light
because I think slo-mo and be money
pointed out like kids they will ravage
up some joy cons or lose the joy
comments right
so if everything's compacting together
they've got to increase the durability
like with the d-pad or laughs fish for
sure I think that's actually probably
one of the design choices behind it
yeah and they also need to make sure
they fix that joy conjurer before when
he comes out cuz you can't like finish
getting sued so I thought we'll be
working on that yeah Kandra in a minute
at all because there's no joy cons I
think I think it's a straight analog
stick I think they yeah exactly
yes the analog stick that's the issue I
think and that can't that can't be a
problem on the many cuz if that's if
that's the issue that's the whole
unicorn vegetable union right there
right yeah they were in trouble right
there because the lawsuit is up the I
gotta you know technology in those joy
cons which I I'm I'm kind of said that
they actually don't use them how they
sell like you when when you played that
one to switch I don't care what anybody
said that was a great demo of your
system demo and like walk away remember
the game that we had a guy and you had
to UM like it was what was it called cut
out or something like that
what happened to that innovation it's
like they started dumbing down all the
games from there and it didn't make the
switch this remember what I kept telling
you guys I want original stuff from
Nintendo right I want the stuff that
they do and everybody thinks I'm bagging
on Nintendo but if you have your lame
exploit your lame please do so but it
seems like they scale back and he's just
started to me too because they started
winning
you know what that and I think a lot of
how to do it water passing away a water
was the last willing to do a lot of that
stuff like at first you know when we
first saw that we're like why are they
releasing this console with a gimmick
HD run one all that stuff but that
that's a water and so once he passed
away I think some of that one with him
as well I think they just decided to
focus on it being as purist system as
possible but I agree with you I mean
that that HD Rumble once you see that
like the ice cubes and one two switch
that was cool absolutely so I know we
gotta get out here but it's just a quick
one a quick hit topically I spent too
long and we get out of here I wanted to
bring this to y'all because I've never
seen it someone shot up a manhole or you
know he's one of the first abridgement
is also soon although
in reference to Kickstarter and you know
I don't know if you guys are paying
attention is this GTA clone it's games
called raw and they had a Kickstarter
you know trying to get this game off the
ground whatever
and apparently raw was suspended by
Kickstarter because they've reached
their goal but then apparently they
started to ask for additional funds and
say you know to get it out to publishers
stuff like that so what the British to
y'all real quick and reference to the
whole you know Kickstarter thing and and
games getting out and do we feel you
know if a game says hey we need funding
for something to get our project to
light you know I'm saying and if you
know they reach their goal or they say
they said oh say if they're transparent
to you and say hey even if we reach this
goal there's still a chance that it
might not come out unless a big-time
publisher picks it up like where's our
stance with this whole Kickstarter
mentality with games being coming out so
first I don't trust Kickstarter's the
first whatever kick-started they're
making have been like oh the money just
mysteriously disappeared or we didn't
put as much money as we could have put
into the game we we're using it for our
personal means and there's like is there
a way for them to get that money back I
know there is like for me I'm just like
why in the world would you ever invest
in a Kickstarter because the chance of
it not working out are super high not
only that not only that it's just like
yeah let me just give my money to this
stranger who might screw me over and I
don't understand what Kickstarter
doesn't have more systems in place to
keep that stuff from happening so that's
another side eye right there 30 trusts
Kickstarter and I certainly don't trust
these devs saying you know we are trying
to make this game but we need you to do
it big look it's funny you said that
because this is kind of like a first a
president has been sent like Kickstarter
suspended this games campaign and we're
like no you are not being transparent
you said that you were gonna you need to
beat this financial goal you read it and
now you're asking for additional funds
so now they told the entire project what
I think
the jump from the jump it was
disingenuous cuz if you tell me that
you're making an MMORPG in the vein of
GTA online or like a rust or something
like that and you tell me yeah all we
need is 80 grand I'm you're lying
you see straight were like yeah you need
more than you know I commend Kickstarter
for jumping in me like know what caught
this from the beginning there's no way
there's no way because if they're
telling you that they're there
guidelines indicate then to ask for the
amount of money that will bring this
game to fruition to more right you're
looking at the game that they're they're
touting to you can't look at it's 80
grand and think that game is gonna get
made so it's it's there's a scheisse
going on there from the beginning so you
need to be vigilant of this stuff from
the beginning sorry let me ask you to
counter point out I don't want the my
boy
hold on hundreds it's my man shot the
whole look but he was saying so what if
in this case brought the developers of
this game was GTA GTA online long said
hey they say they were completely
transparent let's just say yo we need 20
G's to kind of get it off the ground you
know I'm saying then we could shop it to
the publishers and then let's say they
had to 20g tier and then they had it the
ATG do whatever lutely break that down
you delineate each step of the way
what's gonna happen in the pan and
you're clear with the with people
funding the game that they may not get
their money back the hope is is that the
game to himself it gets off the ground
and if they have faith in it it you know
it may be willing to donate then great
but make that clear to people donating
to your game from the beginning you have
to see this is not the Wild West of
Kickstarter when it first started you
can get away with something like this
now they people been burned too much so
they had to put these checks and
balances in place now I wonder what is
the difference between this and star
citizen I mean what is the dead with
star citizen doing good point product
out there is still enough to sort of
satiate the people that are interested
in spending that money on that stuff
mm-hmm so I guess at Lord
hasn't been out that much because for
whatever reason the people have it that
it hadn't invested to this point or fine
enough with the product they have Missy
Missy but that kind that kind of messes
up like Kickstarter's rules their
guidelines because just because the
people are fine with giving their money
to this this you know some people will
say a scam that it's that you're not
gonna shut them down be gonna shut down
this other one that doesn't have quite
enjoy it just seems really uneven the
thing is at least is a product that four
star citizen and I'm not again I'm not
defending them whatsoever I honestly I
think kickstart needs to be blown up and
started oh yeah yeah shout out with JD
gay with the file on a super check
Kickstarter got me with the Shenmue 3
thing I didn't guys feel about the whole
Shenmue 3 kicks down alright if we have
to kick a guy right now I'm in uhm when
it comes to like you see how I do it
betas right I don't wanna play it right
you know so um when a Kickstarter tells
you there are certain tiers to get this
game out when I saw it got to the level
of outrageous is when you told me a game
that would be 50 bucks
give me a thousand dollars are you out
of your mind sir like I don't care what
type of fan animations no I don't care
what you give them free is not even ours
it's not you're talking about two
systems doesn't get listen man if you I
can't defend the fools I can't defend
you if you decide to go and then you
want to plunk down your hard-earned cash
if you don't value your dollar and you
want to go inside a Kickstarter you want
to put five hundred dollars off for
Shenmue that's on you did you see how
much your five hundred hours went to the
face
who is he got exactly what you paid for
sir $500 for frozen face in time will
they get a dollar from me I guess you
will never come out if it's backed upon
me because you're only gonna get the $60
that I will pull it up and I'm hoping
it's coming the game past Oh
Kickstarter brought his whole pigs like
where you had with this whole
precedented move of Kickstarter taking
down a campaign suspending it I mean
I've only ever backed up one Kickstarter
and that was ukulele and it'll only
because like the developers were from
rare you know I mean and they were kind
of making a spiritual successor to banjo
so I was like no I mean I'll support
that I was a big banjo fan back in the
day um but you know I mean all these
Kickstarter's the mighty number nines
and and all the other stuff has been
ridiculous the Shenmue stuff has been
insane and you know I mean for for them
to go in and kick kick these uh disturb
off because if you know what they're
doing
I mean it's understandable you know I
mean you can't go out there and acts
acts for a certain certain amount and
then you know when you exist that go I
want to read this because I gotta ask
them a question shady right and I want
you to be transparent a 2-game I'm gonna
read to see oh my god those are pictures
of the wars in history and this is true
this is the day harking back to the
Dreamcast the animation is it seems like
they're doing it on old dough the motion
capture or dominus that's a em - that's
a good as the heart I don't know what he
might be David
you know who this that's my bad good to
you JD JD gamer uh uh and you don't have
to put this in color cuz I will
definitely read this how much money did
you put down full for the Shamu since
you got got let the world know how much
you got got for ya now I will read it
out there you see how much you spend on
it because this is an active consumer
who's paid his money and he's not happy
with the Kickstarter phases that he's
getting on animation janking people get
their wallets and they have our old Dell
system in the back so we could get it
running under fifty nine hundred and
twenty dollars that's more than the Deaf
kiste you he said don't forget big
starting storing the whole game or ten
five and a half five and a quarter
floppy disk oh boy my heart goes out to
you JD and thank you for sharing with
the chat in the world it sucks because
hopefully they give you the game free
and give you everything with the tremens
that you can get with the game hopefully
they give you the animation facial
package um but I do I do appreciate you
sharing with the room because I wouldn't
gave him a nickel when they said that
and when I told cog I told sovereign it
was like Shamu was coming to a
Kickstarter
you know no you're good but I I just
think it's kicks Kickstarter you know I
mean the whole thing needs to be reset
away yeah I think you know I mean when
you start asking people for more than
what the game costs or more than what
you would charge for a collector's
edition ooh then then I think that's
some of the Kickstarter should look at
you know I mean as as far as their
company is concerned because I think
when you start having people donate five
hundred and thousand dollars and fifteen
hundred dollars just because they they
have some fandom of whatever the say
game is a product that's supposedly
coming I think that that's a little yeah
it becomes you know I make becomes very
scary for the consumer because you know
I mean you will never get back what you
have
I mean donate it and return you know I
mean how could you ever say did you get
$500 worth of symbol you know man
how could you say that your experience
is the same same value as a console
problem like they're not upfront about
all that stuff isn't the fine print all
that stuff is like it tells you you may
not get this money back this this
project may never come to fruition Anil
buyer beware the problem is that they're
not in front about it never been so like
you said some a fan of this franchise
what I become they want to support it
thinking yeah oh my god the game's gonna
come out I'm gonna get my copy of my hot
edition of it not knowing that if they
don't reach certain goals and if they've
been disingenuous about the goals that
they need to reach and they're not gonna
get anything yep but I do want to say
that not all of it is bad and I'm not
gonna say Kickstarter isn't but like
just crowdfunding the crowdfunding games
in general isn't all bad if you look at
obsidian and I don't know if you guys
read the book that you're sure I wrote
oh yeah the chapter about that wouldn't
even be here if we would have even
survived to the point where Microsoft
versus them if it wasn't for them
crowdfunding uh pillars of eternity yeah
and a name saved a stapler company
example got a shout out my dues my dues
warhorse studios the whole
that is a positive example came from
nothing it was a Kickstarter and then it
actually came to fruition after the
development stuff there are there are
some positive stories for him but I
didn't hear which I say it it's off
especially with the the buyer beware the
last thing I want to say on Shenmue 2 is
that a reference to them is specifically
with the whole epic store thing because
a lot of people were pissed off because
remember they were getting the
PlayStation 4 version or PC but thinking
that it was gonna be steamed and then
that whole debacle would ever see so you
know that that was a little bit of messy
luck thankfully epic got ahead of it
they're gonna give these guys I guess
the refunds are so on and so forth
just want to bring that to the round
table as a final topic and get out of
here
but um yeah we got the poll we're gonna
wrap us up with the new our people this
week with the gears 5 multiplayer tech
tests now out in the wild
did your gameplay experience now
positively or negatively affect your
enthusiasm for the game or release date
the choices are a those servers and wait
times are horrible man servers be 4k 60
goodness gears 5 has made me a believer
or launch or see I don't care where that
campaign footage at dump those vile
people when it goes up on Twitter
tomorrow
lady Lucca Bratz podcast be money
slow-mo back slap all in the realm today
we're gonna find people find you what do
you have going on let's our late Libre
okay so thank you so much for having me
I had so much fun you guys are always a
riot like I love it so much
I'm so happy especially that I was here
with my son slow Mobius you know but as
my eldest born son it's just nice to see
him branching out you know living his
life growing up you know he figure out
so fast it was really good you guys can
find on twitter at the ashen luca i have
been minding my
lately and not arguing with folks so you
know kudos to me and I have a podcast
cuts Comcast it is typically every
Saturday at 4 p.m. Central Time which is
5 p.m. Eastern Time and you guys should
come check it out we have a lot of fun
absolutely shout the team shout out to
my Comcast brethren I had nothing but
love and respect for all of those guys I
would name the panel but the panel is
huge and you know they're not always
there all the time they just always a
pleasure in the room the passion is
always there good to have you back and
thank you for answering the call always
much appreciate you know make shout the
braaap obviously you had to dip out but
we got the rest of Brad - EJ and Forte
so I'll be I don't get foam what you
call it but homey so uh yo slow let's do
that shout out baby where you at man
what's going on which you got going on
with that channel so yeah I started my
youtube channel it's been about like
five weeks now maybe like four or five
weeks it's yeah yeah four weeks and
that's long well I'm enjoying it I'm
having fun you checked me out same name
on that I got I probably have a video
out tomorrow about Marvel Ultimate
Alliance three if not tomorrow Tuesday
I'm also on Twitter same name and of
course as you as you mentioned on brat
Wednesdays at 9:00 p.m. Eastern and the
logs come cast at 5 p.m. Eastern where
we like to have fun so thank you fans
for the call brother
always a pleasure the opinions were good
today everything Oh anytime man anytime
you guys need me I'm there held me down
today thank you so much but a much
creature and then we got the legendary P
money back in the building
thank you both answer the call what is
going on man where can people find you
man I appreciate you guys sending the
call out and I'm just glad I was there
to answer you know man so appreciate the
love and always you know there for you
guys and good support you since day one
so keep doing your thing but you can you
can find
me everywhere man same name you know be
money one one everywhere I'm on your
local game gaming console and Twitter
all your social medias now you can
follow me on follow me on Brett you know
Wednesday night snipe you know you see
the time Brooke we go crazy over here
and then on Saturday nights 10:30 p.m.
Eastern Standard Time so no took
podcasts we weren't there to smoke cow
cows or had a little operation or
whatever but we'll be back next week
everybody please reach out to cow girl
wishes I'm some well what'd you get well
right now clean up to JD game of guess
the two scuba chats I don't know if Luka
heard but ya know he put what he put on
shout-out to Luka he put on a great show
yeah much appreciated you might be onto
something please everybody tick podcast
hope wish him well I'm saying thank you
for putting us on to that as well and
also Abby thank you so much brother man
coming through it's been a minute I was
there I was like you being me I gotta
hit me up because there's a glue for b2
coming through and of course the Lords
of the realm attic get Wells there he's
another one please get well but of
course the single player switch traitor
Lord starving in the relative I hope you
extended family the brat podcast local
immensely a double duty well you can
catch me of bashing Marvel to Milan
sweets and I will not give you that
social security number but you can catch
me on xbox and em and PSN @bx sovereign
and I'll be on Twitter I'll be playing
oh that blood-stained man that blood
state is so good speaking of of
kickstart is that were actually
successful except for me do a Swiss
version that blood stain is amazing dude
Lord King we had a to Vasco for me too
back to the BX reason SS we use on our
grind hustling it's good what you got
okay well um as you can see the basement
still not finished you know they get in
there this weekend we gotta sit there
and start doing the details on that get
that bathroom done um Kos is gonna be up
this week Oh we'll have a kale was
didn't want to give you out too much
content on one spot because you had the
last word yeah combat talk and you have
the show now so on Monday I'm gonna drop
a Kos it's just a small Kos about the
statue breaking and that information so
you guys who are out there actively
collecting you want to know what units
to purchase and stuff like that I'm
gonna go through that with you guys
but um as well I'm sitting here I got
more statues coming in I have a school
civ statue up there that I got and I'm
a-goin going to the unbox and I was
gonna do it today but then the panel
got wide open so we're not gonna do
today but I'm gonna do a special one for
that because that's a special gift and
that is gonna go up um but we are out
here moving we love the community we
love you guys I love every each and
every last one of these people that's on
this panel let me let me tell you first
of all Luka has been definitely
supporting us 100% and that's why I
thought that Saturday Saturday I came to
Saturday's it's very hard for me but I
definitely made it to you sure 100%
slo-moes might do yes well I love I
don't care what nobody say slow mo back
slap that is B never ever change your
avatar all right and be money the money
has been there with us since our infancy
and um that's my dude like and I can't
wait to have a drink with you and sit
there next year when we really kicked
this gaming stuff as they get the turkey
legs and he drinks again oh yeah so we
got so much fun man to rule was in it to
him that's when I broke out in hives
thank you very much
I don't eat meat and my behind call
myself biting a turkey leg because why
the does the wind out there and went all
out so I said you know what let me die
today
for that the del URI no and of course
myself you already know what the final
route several reviews is up now know
it's a little late but we got that spike
made off from home I made Lord Jamie's
been filling in cuz I saw it late
solving them soared ahead of me it's my
fault I was in Guardian cause I missed
you you know their butts all we got to
get back in pocket well I think we
should I mean later in the year we have
Joker yeah you things that we probably
wouldn't normally go see that we would
ditch stitch is having a baby next week
Oh congrats in advance sir amazing show
Monica 10 don't talk being petty to have
escape topics salute to that brother man
but not congratulations in advance on
the new one coming through like next
Friday load low young switch out of
realm you know saying that be dope so
well yeah Mike I said we got that up
going all right there and then I just
want to give a quick shout out like as
far as on the team Lord gave me done
that y'all loving the support much
appreciated like teens working extremely
hard dizzy all the crew here I'm said
Josh ready and gondolas Condor Lloyd
hide the admin Nord mods out here
killing it now man said so Condor
everybody biggie Jersey please when you
see them articles the retweets that all
that stuff really helps us to get better
content to you guys so we go to these
shows we could pull up you know I mean
so much appreciative whole support for
Lords of gaming that net and please make
sure you're following at Lords gaming
net so you can get that latest gaming
news in yo feed so please do that show
to support but that's all I gotta hit
that like subscribe all that other good
stuff we will be back up in the realm
next Sunday if anybody got anything else
if not we are out big